c'est tout un peuple du Sud et tout un
peuple au niveau mondial qui aime la
corrida ici c'était si
peu aimé il y aurait pas des millions
d'amis qui viendraient
chaque année au feria alors c'est
Solveig je vous présente mon épouse non
non
il nous donnera son avis dans un instant
alors Cathy est-ce qu'on peut vous
décaler qu'un Solveig va s'asseoir
[Rires]
la question
faut-il interdire la corrida oui oui oui
Delphine Solveig vous inquiétez pas elle
va donner son avis tout à l'heure quand
on voit ces images déjà je trouve les
toréador là ils sont ils sont ridics
encore une fois je pense et je te
l'avais tu as dit à toi je pense qu'il y
a un problème de masculinité là-dessus
pour
se pour ce vanter bomber le torse avec
des armes face à une bête qui elle n'a
pas d'armes c'est un combat qui n'est
pas du tout égal et quand vous dites que
les arènes sont pleines enfin il y a
quand même je crois 74% des Français qui
sont contre donc il faut que ça évolue
en son temps il y a plein de traditions
qui existaient dans le temps dans le
temps couper la tête des gens aussi
voilà la justice faisait que on les
guillotinait aujourd'hui ça n'existe
plus donc il y a des problèmes
qui étaient terribles
en bois il y avait des gens qui
faisaient des sabots genre
ce que je voudrais dire c'est
qu'évidemment vous l'avez vu sur la
vidéo on tue un animal et ça peut
paraître violent en revanche ce que je
voudrais dire c'est qu'on tue des
millions d'animaux chaque jour jusque là
et voilà et que citez-moi un autre
animal qui est tué sous le regard pourra
vous en parler sous le regard et sous le
contrôle de 15000 regards 15000
personnes contrôlent lorsque Marc va
tuer le taureau 15000 personnes le
regard des si il rate son est stocks
s'ils tue mal l'animal si la mort n'est
pas foudroyante et rapide tout le monde
va lever il a ce poids sur les épaules
est-ce que dans les abattoirs 15000
regards contrôle la mort de la minimale
non où est la fierté alors Marc Serrano
matador d'abord ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est de l'animal de laquelle on parle
on parle pas d'un animal domestique on
ne parle pas d'un animal correctaire
tout le monde à venir au moins une fois
dans sa vie en élevage si vous voulez
pas venir au cours vous n'y allez pas et
venir en avoir je vais voir comment ça
vie un taureau de corrida il faut savoir
qu'il se battent un truc qui se tue
entre eux vous comprenez bien la
spécificité cette race j'ai vu des
taureaux se battre un illicéré
complètement marchant sur ces viscères
continuez à se battre jusqu'à la mort
rien que pour ça je veux que l'on
comprenne on est on n'aime pas mais que
l'on comprenne de l'animal dans laquelle
parce que cet après-midi en fait
Raphaël très très mignon d'ailleurs
c'est le discours des gens qui
connaissent les taureaux un discours
bien rodé
c'est une réalité qu'on voulait pas
entendre parce que aujourd'hui
moi aujourd'hui lorsque je t'aurais et
je vais vous choquer mais si une vérité
personne
si vous me coupez tout le temps je peux
pas m'exprimer non mais je l'ai déjà
entendu
alors moi au jour d'aujourd'hui ce que
je vais dans l'arène j'accepte de mourir
j'accepte de mourir par amour pour cet
animal parce qu'il mérite une mort digne
c'est 40 ans j'ai reçu 8 coups de corne
j'ai trois services et j'accepte de
mettre cette animal en méta ma vie en
danger parce que je le respecte je ne me
cache pas derrière un fusil dans un
abattoir ou quoi que ce soit je le fais
devant tout le monde et j'accepte de
mourir j'accepte de mourir pour ma
passion et par passion pour cet animal
parce que c'est un animal hors norme et
qui mérite une humourdine pour moi c'est
devant 20 000 personnes dans la lumière
et avec une personne qui va mettre sa
vie en danger comme lui donc c'est un
combat équitable alors vous avez quand
même le la longueur des lances donc
c'est pas tout à fait
toi pour te faire
mais vous dites
j'accepte de mourir mais le taureau lui
il a pas le choix monsieur moi je vais
vous dire à tous les deux tout
simplement à mes yeux vous êtes des
meurtriers voilà vous tuez pour votre
plaisir des taureaux qui n'ont rien
demandé c'est un meurtre rituel au nom
de la tradition vous êtes des barbares
je ne comprends même pas comment vous
osez vous exprimer c'est bien que vous
soyez là mais franchement c'est une
passion meurtrière vous tuez des
taureaux pour votre bon plaisir vous
rendez compte monsieur vous rendez
compte abolissons la corrida tout de
suite interdisons là
sur Marie moi je suis allé un coup à une
corrida m'a emmené j'ai vomi sur moi
dans les gradins moi je suis mal tombé
le torero était pas terrible une un coup
d'épée qui reste à moitié en dehors on
la récupère et la replante ensuite des
sauts de sang qui sortent par les
narines il voulait pas mourir ce taureau
j'avais et moi je me suis vomi dessus
dans la tribune ça c'est la première
chose ensuite les coutumes puisque on
parle de tradition la tradition on doit
pas y toucher si si bien sûr qu'on y
touche à la tradition je disais tout à
l'heure après la guillotine on a
supprimé l'empalement l'empalement
c'était sympa aussi hein bon il y a des
tas d'autres choses qui vont être
supprimées la chasse à courre pendant la
chasse à courre la chasse à courre ne
peut pas perdurer c'est pas parce que il
y a une poignée de de mecs qu'on souvent
assez friqués qui se régale d'aller
chasse à courre mais c'est pas possible
tu vois le cerf on va jusqu'à épuisement
total et une meute au cul et Jean-Marie
à la fin on le tue on met des heures
pour le tuer et le pauvre sert des fois
il met un coup de tête encore dans la
langue
il faut il faut il faut aussi comprendre
que on fait la tête et la queue oui les
oreilles à la queue on lui enlève les
oreilles là Turner un petit peu c'est le
même principe les oreilles et la queue
non mais chacun son tour
donc voilà il faut savoir qu'on arrache
les oreilles la queue donc je demande à
ce que ceux qui le fassent subissent
pas quand il est vivant bien sûr donc en
fait il est temps que les sociopathes
qui s'isent exercer ce qu'ils pratiquent
à Paris serait en prison donc vous
invitez des sociopathes il faut savoir
que monsieur est à l'extrême droite bien
sûr affiner à l'extrême droite et que
vous vous avez été condamné pour pour
diffamation non pour agression vous avez
accusé d'agression sexuelle mais il me
semble que vous avez été condamné en
diffamation non non pour diffamation
et dans la corrida le meurtre ne se
retient plus celui qui m'a violé torture
des taureaux il fait des spectacles
entiers de soutien à la pratique sadiste
il a déclaré la corrida est un art le
sexe est un art comme Eric
Dupont-Moretti comme Pablo Picasso quand
même c'est un aveu de meurtre c'est un
aveu de viol et il est grand temps que
le spectacle de la cruauté de la
barbarie la plus absolu ne soit ne soit
plus une vantardise car derrière
évidemment le couteau qui perce la nuque
en privé en public en privé se
transforme en couteau qui coupe la gorge
alors ça c'est ce sont des millions et
des millions de bovins qui sont
assassinés tous les jours le monde
entier est une arène il est temps que le
spectacle le plus cynique le plus
complexé soit aboli et il va être abolie
car nous ne laisserons pas faire les
sociologues
parce que là c'est déjà compliqué Marc
ce que dit cette dame bien évidemment je
suis pas d'accord avec elle parce que je
veux pas vous
auriez la queue les oreilles d'accord
est-ce qu'on laisse parler c'est
toujours la même chose avec vous vous
êtes une fasciste
elle est calme
je suis désolé
on est chez Bolloré
oui voilà
que c'était une tradition du Sud et bien
que l'esclavage c'est une tradition du
Sud nous sommes en terre de taureau
magie nous avons l'extrême droite invité
en place d'honneur et la diffamation et
la diffamation
moi j'ai jamais été condamné madame pour
rien vous êtes attendez c'est à suivre
elle parleront de toute façon
qui fait l'apologie de la corrida se
vante de se branler devant les
documentaires de la Shoah c'est dans ses
livres il se vendent des aigle
attention
doit disparaître
pour la première fois sur un plateau ce
serait bien de l'entendre une tradition
puisque
la parole
qu'est-ce que vous avez à dire à un
matador en plateau c'est la première
fois voilà
la parole à un meurtrier c'est très
dangereux
je suis là pour être le porte-voix des
martyrs des martyrs
taureau des martyrs des martyrs génies
vous voulez pas lui parler mon frère
vache ma sœur les génies contre le
génisme on ne dialogue on ne dialogue
pas avec on est dialogue pas avec le
danger les jambes extrêmement dangereux
on les combats de foot il faut descendre
dans les arènes il faut descendre dans
les libérer les martyrs
je vais vous remercier
par les gens c'est pas possible et c'est
parler les autres
machines
je vous remercier
c'était très important
un jour où il y aura un
vous avez honte à vous de voir ce que je
voudrais dire
bonjour
parce qu'on avait on avait les
protagonistes en argent je suis contre
la corrida on a un torero ici on a un
mec qui fait caca
on est avec toi
on avait un gars qui fait ça non mais
laisse-le parler le mec qui était là
c'est son métier de faire ça
le mec qui tue les taureaux il était là
tu vois ils sont partis fini les mots il
faut déjà c'est n'importe quoi
[Applaudissements]
ça m'intéressait ce qu'il avait à dire
le gars et tu des taureaux ça
m'intéresse plus que ton mascara ta mère
on est d'accord pourquoi tu laisses
partir c'est une pratique d'homme
sadique
des femmes magnifiques hommage à toutes
les femmes qui manifestent à toutes les
femmes dans les arènes qui regardent le
spectacle il y a plein de femmes dans
les arènes est-ce que vous voulez
discuter avec Géraldine c'est une
pratique sadique ne me coupez pas la
queue